BUT FIRST MY FIRST OPEN.
IF YOU THOUGHT THERE WAS A LOT
OF IN-FIGHTING IN THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY WHEN DONALD TRUMP RAN IN
THE 2016 PRESIDENTIAL PRIMARY
AGAINST 16 OTHER CANDIDATES,
STRAP IN AND GRAB YOUR POPCORN.
THE DEMOCRAT PRIMARY PROMISES TO
BE AN ALL-OUT BARE KNUCKLE
BEATDOWN CLOWN SHOW.
AND ALTHOUGH IT'S BEEN FOUR
YEARS SINCE HILLARY AND BERNIE
DIEWRKD IT OUT IN THE PRIMARY
WITH HILLARY'S CASH ON THE DNC'S
SCALES.
WE KNOW VERY LIT ABOUT WHAT THE
DEMOCRATS ACTUALLY STAND FOR.
WHAT WE DO KNOW IS THEY STILL
HATE PRESIDENT TRUMP NOW MORE
THAN EVER.
EVERY OTHER MESSAGE PRESENT NET
I CAN, FRENZIED AND HYSTERICAL.
EVERY MESSAGE IS A BIT MORE LEFT
AND PROGRESSIVE.
THEY KEEP GOING SO FAR LEFT I'M
WAITING FOR THEM TO FALL OFF THE
EDGE OF THE EARTH.
BUT THEN AGAIN THE EARTH IS
ROUND, UNLESS THEY UPIRNTDED
THAT TRUTH, TOO.
THIS WEEK OTHER SIDE, PRESIDENT
TRUMP DEMONSTRATED CLEAR
LEADERSHIP IN HIS OFFICIAL
KICKOFF ANNOUNCEMENT FOR A
SECOND TERM.
IF EVER THERE WAS A WEEK TO SEE
HIM TURN THE FOCUS ON SPOTLIGHT
ON HIMSELF OF WHICH HE IS
MASTER, THIS WAS IT.
PEOPLE WAITED TWO DAYS IN THE
POURING RAIN.
MANY OF THEM NOT EVEN GETTING
INTO THE EVENT.
THE MAN CAN DRAW A CROWD, CREATE
ENTHUSIASM, BRING BACK
PATRIOTISM, AND MAKE PEOPLE
PROUD OF AMERICA.
THERE WERE WELL OVER 100,000
REQUESTS AND OVER 20,000 PEOPLE
SEATED INSIDE.
THIS KIND OF ENTHUSIASM HAS
NEVER BEEN MATCHED IN AMERICAN
HISTORY.
AND I DON'T CARE WHAT POLL, WHAT
NETWORK, WHAT STATISTICAL GENIUS
TELLS YOU.
THERE IS A CHORD THIS MAN
STRIKES IN THE AMERICAN HEART.
THE AMERICAN DREAM THAT THE LEFT
CAN'T DESTROY NO MATTER HOW HARD
THEY TRY.
THE DAY AFTER HIS RALLY, HE
RAISED NEARLY $25 MILLION.
THE LARGEST ONE-DAY HAUL BY ANY
CANDIDATE IN PRESIDENTIAL
HISTORY.
SO, AS HE STAYS STRONG AND LASER
FOCUSED ON HIS STRENGTH AND THE
ROCKETING ECONOMY WITH
OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL AMERICANS TO
BE PART OF THE AMERICAN DREAM,
THE DEMOCRAT CLOWN CAR
OVERLOADED WITH 23 CANDIDATE
BUMBLES DOWN THE PATH TO
NOWHERE.
LIKE CANNONBALLS, THEIR PLAN NOT
SO MUCH TO PROMOTE THEMSELVES AS
IT IS TO EAT EACH OTHER ALIVE.
EXAMPLE.
AS IF THEIR SUPPOSED FRONTRUNNER
JOE BIDEN DOESN'T HAVE ENOUGH
PROBLEMS BEING WHO IS.
PAST PLAGIARISMS ILLUSTRATE HIS
LACK OF DEPTH ON CERTAIN
SUBJECTS.
HIS PENCHANT TO STICK HIS NOSE
ON WOMEN'S NECKS.
I DON'T KNOW ANY OTHER
TWO-LEGGED DOGS WHO SNIFF LIKE
CREEPY JOE.
YOU HEAR WHAT HIS COLORADO PALS
SAY ON THE HYDE AMENDMENT.
ONE DAY THE GOVERNMENT SHOULD
NOTE PAY FOR APPORTIONS.
THE NEXT DAY THEY SHOULD.
THE LATEST MESS, IS FELLOW
DEMOCRATS SAVAGE THEM ON
SEGREGATION.
JOE SAYS HE CAN WORK WITH
ANYBODY.
WITH WITH
ANYONE.
AND HE'S SHOULD BELY A RACIST.
>> HE'S SPEAKING WITH ADORATION
INDIVIDUAL WHO MADE AND BUILT
THEIR REPUTATION ON SEGREGATION.
SO THIS IS A VERY SERIOUS
MATTER.
>> I HAVE DONE NOTHING WRONG,
YOU SHOULD APOLOGIZE, I'M NOT A
RACIST IS SO INSULTING AND SO
MISSING THE LARGER POINT.
THAT HE SHOULD NOT HAVE TO
EXPLAIN IT.
>> I TO BE SINGING THE PRAISES
OF PEOPLE WHO WERE VICIOUS
SEGREGATIONISTS IS NOT
SOMETHING --
>> HE WAS TALKING ABOUT WORKING
WITH THEM.
IS THAT THE SAME SNING.
>> I'M NOT SO SURE.
JUDGE JEANINE: I DON'T REMEMBER
THINGS BEING THIS BAD 15 MONTHS
BEFORE THE REPUBLICAN PRIMARY.
AND WHAT'S WITH JOE'S SON?
I'M THE FIRST ONE TO SAY A
FAMILY MEMBER'S BEHAVIOR IS
TOTALLY IRRELEVANT TO THE
CANDIDATE.
BUT YOU CANNOT HERE.
JOE BIDEN ADMITS THAT WHEN HIS
SON HUNTER WAS WORK FOR AN
ENERGY COMPANY IN THE UKRAINE.
HE, JOE, THREATENED THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UKRAINE THAT HE
WOULD WITH HOLD $1 BILL U.S.
DOLLARS IF THE PROSECUTOR
INVESTIGATING THE ENERGY COMPANY
WHERE HIS SON WORKED WAS NOT
FIRED.
CURIOUSLY HIS SON HAD NO
BACKGROUND IN ENERGY AND WAS
MAKE $50,000 A MONTH.
BIDE BE IS SO STUPID HE PROUDLY
ADMITS THAT AFTER HIS THREAT,
THE PROSECUTOR WAS FIRED.
SHADE OF THE CLINTON DEMOCRATS
WHERE FOREIGN POLICY IS SHAPED
TO BENEFIT THE FAMILY
POCKETBOOK.
AND EVEN JOE'S BEST PAL BARACK
IS UNCHARACTERISTIC ALL SILENT
THESE DAYS.
JOE HAS TO REMIND HIM THAT THEY
ARE BESTIES WITH THE BEST FRIEND
FOREVER BRACELET.
JOE, I WOULDN'T HOLD MY BREATH
WAITING FOR YOUR BEST PAL BARACK
TO ENDORSE YOU.
MAYBE HE'S WAITING FOR THE
PERFECT DAY WET SUN, THE MOON,
THE STARS AND ALL THE PLANETS
ARE ALIGNED TO SIGNAL JOE, YOU
ARE THE ONE.
BUT IN THE MEANTIME, JOE, YOU
WILL PROBABLY MAKE A PRETTY
LOUSY PRESIDENT.
SO STICK TO MAKING YOUR
FRIENDSHIP BRACELETS AND WISHING
AND HOPING.
AMERICA DOESN'T NEED A BEST
FRIEND OR A SNIFF OR PLAGIARIST,
OR SOMEONE SO DUMB HE ADMITS
THREATENING TO WITH HOLD
GOVERNMENT MONEY TONED AN
INVESTIGATION ON A COMPANY WHERE
A FAMILY MEMBER IS INVOLVED.
IN THE END, IT WON'T MATTER
BECAUSE TRUMP IS IN A
LAMBORGHINI.